today I'm game life it's our top five
games with stories in them I do like
stories don't you that's right you are
watching the all new game life podcasts
in our brand-new studio so here's the
thing it is two months almost two months
out from the release of BioShock
Infinite and man I am still thinking
about it and I really wanted to discuss
it with you today Peter Rubin but for
some reason you haven't finished
bioshock infinite yet i'm taking my
sweet languorous time with it is why but
but while i haven't finished bioshock
infinite and thus we cannot speak about
bioshock infinite for fear of spoiling
me to the experience it did put us in
mind of the role of story in video games
so we present to you our top five
favorite stories in video games now
before I get into this I actually want
to make a quick distinction and that is
between story and writing obviously
writing has gotten so incredible in
recent years so much of that is is
studios and developers placing a premium
on writing bringing in big name riders
but story to me is a different beast
it's a combination of world-building
sure and dialogue and characterization
and use you can have a great story
without saying a word right and it's not
necessarily about writing lines of
dialogue it's funny you say that because
my number five is actually a tie between
machinarium and limbo now these are two
very small games limbo was a
downloadable that started on xbox live
arcade imaginarium was a pc and an iOS
title both were immersive moving
experiences that didn't need a word of
dialogue to get their point across funny
that's your number five because my
number five is something with nothing
but dialogue my number five is eternal
darkness sanity's requiem for the
nintendo gamecube i think that it needs
to be mentioned here because i think
it's a very underrated game in what it
did with its story you played is like 12
different characters it was a sort of i
was an ode to Lovecraft for this sort of
Cthulhu style horror story that I mean I
don't think anybody'd really ever
experienced anything like this on
consoles at that moment that's a fair
point and for number four in a similar
kind of contextual vein I want to talk
about a game that kind of rediff
find what story could do and so my
number four is Telltale Games Walking
Dead saga from last year that's this
just your number four I think if it were
an original IP I might rank it much
higher but this was a licensed property
this is something that was already at
the forefront of pop culture so it was
already enough in the zeitgeist this was
almost an incremental change rather than
an exponential one but what it managed
to do in the emotional impact of a video
game i think was unparalleled well I you
know we'll talk a little bit more about
the walking dead later that I have a
feeling well I think so um my number
four is actually the game portal a lot
of the story of portal was kind of like
in the background of portal the entire
time you know you really had to like
stretch your brain to kind of figure out
what was going on cuz there was only one
character in portal GLaDOS whoever
actually spoke but but it's all there
for you to find well maybe let's not
talk about portal too much because we're
gonna be talking about it in a little
bit okay now just move on to my number
three okay which is grim fandango from
tim schafer now on sheer inventiveness
and world building alone this made it on
my list I mean this is a cross between
film noir imagery and Aztec mythology
you are essentially a private eye
investigator who is wandering through
purgatory looking for your mad before
everyone gets to the the final
underworld stage of their demise yes so
obviously the lucasarts adventure games
in the Sierra adventure games that whole
family of pointing flick games has great
stories and that's why I'm gonna put it
number three Telltale's The Walking Dead
even though it is a licensed property I
had not seen one episode of the
television show before I started playing
The Walking Dead and so for me it was
just the walking dead game was just the
walking dead game the way that it just
pulled you into that story and put you
into the role that main character it did
something that I don't think any other
game prior to it had had pulled off that
great trick of making you care about the
characters in that game and the fact
that there were all these videos on
YouTube oh yeah the camera on them as
they played through and saw the
consequences of their choice is borne
out as they played don't you put her
hand in her pants for oh my god you
serious I would have loved to have seen
all of this for people who are playing
you know some older games that you know
grim
and dango if they were playing that for
the first time with their reactions were
they been I would like to see that same
thing for my number two which is
bioshock from irrational games the the
first bioshock from the moment that you
happened on that island and descended in
the bathysphere you had no idea what was
in store for you all you knew is you
were somewhere that a video game had
never taken you before and how the game
just mounted layer on layer the fact
that there was such overt political
overtones in it i mean just everything
about it was absolutely epochal and
pivotal for me right yeah who knew they
were gonna make a video game essentially
about its creators disagreements with
I'm brand of all people um so my number
two is again a game that is a product of
its time it's Final Fantasy 6 for the
Super Nintendo gotta represent the final
fantasy games in here especially Final
Fantasy 6 at this point it was nineteen
ninety-four when this game came out okay
and here was an actual story about
characters that like they didn't feel
like cartoony caricatures that so many
role-playing games were dealing with it
this point they actually it really felt
like it was telling the story of this
group of human beings they took the
Super Nintendo and just squeeze so much
juice out of it you know to make it look
so beautiful and again in 1994 for that
to happen it was that for me was
mind-blowing I mean that instant for me
was just like I cannot believe that
video games can do this absolutely so my
number one is the orange box from valve
and I'll tell you why not even a video
it is not a video game it is Team
Fortress 2 the original portal and
half-life 2 and it's other episodes okay
let me tell you why what portal one did
it had one voice actor and I'd had the
mystery that you uncovered as you went
through the facility yeah what half-life
2 did yes was give you a first-person
shooter that was a transformation of a
human being just every minute of that
game was an absolute altering experience
dedicated to that the Ark of that
character who you were playing yes and
there's nothing that's the story like
that even team fortress 2 there's a
fantastic backstory to this though
hiccup on if you play this as a fan of
the game right it's all buried and if ya
wards scrutiny and that's why for me
orange box is my number one okay well we
may have already mentioned my number one
because my number one is in fact
I owe shock I would totally put this at
the top of games with stories that just
absolutely captivated me bioshock's
story the the big twist that it all
leads up to it's not something that you
could guess but it's something that that
changes not only your view of the game
but it actually makes you think about
like the nature of video games
themselves when you when you find out
that you were a slave when you find out
that the game we know that there was a
person in your ear telling you what to
do when you did it you know as the
player of this game you're like cheese
you know video games tell me to do
things all the time and I just do them
you know why is it that I just do the
thing the video game tells me too
because there's a voice in my ear
there's so much to love about bioshock
in the way that it tells a story and
it's like I don't want to put BioShock
Infinite on this list cuz it's so new
sit with what I have to say lightning
struck twice with that game yep you know
we have a few months ago we had a
feature in in Wired magazine about kind
of the making of BioShock Infinite and
everything that ken Levine was putting
on this game and how much of him and
just his entire consumptive palate
informed this game and how all these
disparate influences came together to
create this tapestry that was like
nothing gamers had ever seen before and
he certainly accomplished that on one
hand I'm a shame that I'm not finished
with the game on the other hand I'm like
why'd you suckers rush through this
right I'm just having a grand old time
just painstakingly coming over this
thing and those are our top fives well
close to I mean we had a few games in
common there was a lot of overlap it was
it was sort of a collective top seven
but hey I'm sure that you guys have a
lot of thoughts and opinions to about
what games had the best stories what
games stories moved you the most so let
us know in the comments tell us maybe if
you got a great top five list there it
could end up on a future show who knows
we're crazy like that
hey do you like this new game life video
podcasts I do do you want this delivered
directly into your eyeballs all the time
oh you're not talking to me are you I am
NOT talking to you Peter I'm talking to
them and I'm telling them to subscribe
on Wired's YouTube channel to receive
the game life video podcast do it today